ça lui connaît enfin la date de
diffusion du prochain concert des
[ __ ] il s'agit du 5 mars prochain
dans une semaine donc dès 21h05 sur tf1
les téléspectateurs pourront découvrir
les sketches et reprise d'une ribambelle
de stars réunies pour la bonne cause
maintenant
l'édition enregistrait la halle tony
garnier de lyon en janvier dernier une
édition qui cette année est un peu
spécial en raison de la crise sanitaire
ce qui change pour nous autres en foire
est cette année principalement c'est
l'absence de public dans la salle parmi
les artistes présents on retrouve par
exemple patrick bruel zazie amel ben
blaque m ou encore cab adams qui fait là
son entrée dans la troupe
une liste qui se renouvelle mais dont
quelques grands noms manquent à l'appel
la faute à la mauvaise ambiance dans les
coulisses ton des rumeurs parlent depuis
des années pas du tout si on en croit
pascal obispo ce sont de mauvaises
langues comme d'habitude ou encore mimie
mathy on n'est pas payé il n'ya pas des
go on est juste heureux d'être là pour
la bonne cause autant depuis le départ
de jean jacques goldman en 2016 on sent
que la troupe n'est plus aussi soudé
qu'avant c'est par exemple le cas d'eddy
mitchell qui jugent l'humour de ce
concert pitoyable ou encore yannick noah
qui n'aiment pas l'hypocrisie des
artistes durant cette tournée
alors comprenez vous que des stars
refuse de participer aux [ __ ]
et
dur
y'a bien lotis bien faire et il est
d'ailleurs pour soutenir les [ __ ]
était un don donc point
restosducoeur.org et meriem palomba
directrice déléguée du pôle c est dit
public
hihi paris france dimanche elle est là
mais rien de palombes à directrice
déléguée on sera jamais nos directeurs
les délégués ont signalé ces délégués
voilà merci comment ça va me regarde
secteur vient eh ben je suis contente de
revoir ma chérie elle était dans non
bien sûr tpm people oui vous avez
travaillé avec magali berlin oui mais
vous avez travaillé avec les plus grands
[Rires]
alors ça c'est suis un petit peu de plus
ce but de bague au doigt et puis bien
entendu elle est passée de 3 fois la
clinique des choses et c'est comme ça
qu'on l'ait ma chérie alors l'ambiance
au sein de la troupe
on va revenir sur cette ambiance au sein
de la troupe depuis quelques années
maintenant les en soirée doivent faire
face à des rumeurs concernant une
mauvaise ambiance
voilà des rumeurs démenties par me
mathier pascal obispo derrière parce que
c'est vrai c'est moche cette mauvaise
ambiance où pas de
ah oui bien sûr c'est hyper vrai alors
évidemment comme c'est senna c'est pour
une association pour la bonne cause j'ai
toujours pas s'il va bien tout se passe
bien mais les tensions sont là depuis
début mars où jean jacques goldman y
avait plein d'artistes qui était mis sur
le côté c'est toujours à pourquoi lui il
chante ça là le au moment de concerts et
films et il ya des petites guéguerres
aussi parce qu'il ya des filles à des
chanteurs qui chantent beaucoup quand
c'est pas filmer et puis on va mettre
plus en avant d'autres personnes quand
ce temps c'est le tournage il ya eu
aussi des guerres entre michaël youn
pascal obispo ce que bon bah ils ont une
petite amie en commun alors c'est moi je
connais bien miquel franchement ils sont
on oublie qu'ils sont ont très bien avec
pascal aussi ses deux potes en fait je
vous dis la vérité je les connais très
bien pu remarquer certaines années sur
le conte c'est sûr c'est pas des rumeurs
s'améliore boutinon c'est pas des
rumeurs alors parce que quand il ya
beaucoup de personnalités déjà regardé à
nous et on a des gars ils n'ont pas la
carrière ni de mickey minnie mickey n'a
pas ici donc c'est vrai la carrière de
michael youn risque à l'aube ils se
posent voilà tous et c'est vrai que
voilà il peut avoir des petites tensions
entre les équipes mais ça n'empêche pas
qu'ils s'entendent super bien qu'ils
sont contents mine de rien se retrouver
même si parfois il ya des petites
guéguerres entre eux ces voix là
il ya forcément des guerres ce que l'on
sait comme il le dit c'est une grande
colonie de vacances et que c'était ça
après il ya quand même dans les [ __ ]
il ya des clans et à des gens voilà qui
sont qui sont là depuis longtemps qui
font un peu la pluie et le beau temps et
puis les jeunes artistes qui sont
certains sont mis de côté en souvient de
lam lam ça a été terrible pour elle de
participer au tournage et puis il ya eu
des guerres aussi entre filles parce que
quand vous avez alors je sais qu'elle a
beaucoup démenti et que ça fait tout un
tas ta foi mais sa tentative est
l'heureux papa fonds autres jenifer et
nolwenn pendant des années ça a été
hyper hyper compreniez donc
donc voilà on alors c'est normal vous me
direz effectivement ils sont tous
ensemble ils faisant semblant dépendance
compte que même si un jour mais ça m est
vraiment bon alors c'est pas c'est vrai
alors moi moi je vous avais parlé que de
potes et je le dis voilà je dis la
vérité c'est vrai que dans le one est
d'une férocité m'entends très bien avec
elle je savais pas qu'elle est petite de
la guéguerre entre elles guillaume
genton voit ce qu'on m'a dit c'est que
là et j'ai une très bonne source qui m'a
dit que la mauvaise ambiance il ya
quelques années était due au fait que
les artistes au top n'était pas dans les
[ __ ] il ya beaucoup d'artistes qui
sont partis dès en forêt comme jean
jacques goldman et les artistes qui
étaient en haut des classements des
charts était pas dans les [ __ ] et
depuis qu'il ya par exemple soprano vita
slimane et vianney
du coup ça donne envie à d'autres
artistes de venir il ya toujours des
artistes qui refusent de venir comme
luan par exemple il essaye vraiment
d'avoir loi n'y arrive pas à la voir et
au niveau des leaders on se demande qui
est le nouveau leader des [ __ ] après
le le dr
moi on m'a dit patrick fiori qui gère
beaucoup justement quand il ya des
conflits etc notamment sur les titres
d'accor asie et slimane ces mêmes qui
composent également qui s'occupe
beaucoup de la direction artistique
donc c'est vous ce serait même envolé
nouveau leader des [ __ ] oaxaca
essayer d'être effet violé parce que ça
il s'entendait pas avec votre pote
michael youn et pourtant il a écrit
plusieurs plusieurs hymnes c'est sacré
un écrit plusieurs oui les plus fortes
est fort oui gilles verdez moi je suis
pour que tout le mondial mais il ya des
normes polémique et surtout certaines
stars qui vont là-bas confondent la loi
de charité avec de la promo vous vous
souvenez que thomas sotto quand il était
sur bfm avait fait un tweet
il devait accueillir garou pour une
interview il avait annulé l'interview
parce que l'attaché de presse de garou
avait exigé que ce soit 50% restos du
coeur 50% sur son nouveau disque regard
neuf et ses valeurs il ya aussi je vous
dis c'est pas lui gardons les mêmes poko
hangar où il est venu de chez nous il
avait même pas de promo gare ou non mais
non abonnés non mais pour vous dire
qu'il est pas il n'est pas croit la
promo gardien il est venu ici d'année
mais pas de provoquer en tout cas
l'interview avait été annulé et lui
permet et beaucoup y met beaucoup de
stars viennent là bas vincent france
aime ça moi j'ai répondu non mais il
faut pas dissimuler
valérie est ce que tu penses un seul
instant que la personne qu'il va faire
la queue aux restos du coeur se dit j'ai
l'impression que garou en fait il s'est
fait de la promo sur en faisant les
restos du coeur non il se dit simplement
heureusement quai des artistes qui sont
remontés sur scène parce que je peux
faire la queue et je peux avoir grâce à
ces cds là un repas il se pose pas la
question de savoir est ce qu'il a fait
de la promo sur mon dos et moi je pense
que le principal c'est qu'il faut
rappeler que c'est un cd un cd s'est dit
c'est trop loin et qu'il faut rappeler
que là en ce moment comme n'y a pas eu
de temps ya pas eu de public ses 4,2
millions de manque à gagner donc on en a
besoin et donc on s'en fiche des
polémiques et peu importe mais la laci
viennent se faire pousser du col à
valérie là on parle pas des restos du
coeur bien entendu au parvis
le spectacle est de l'ambiance de route
bien sûr chaque action à chaque fois en
addition mousse etc
je m'en fous s'il vient c'est aussi un
talent derrière nous mais c'est pas
grave
en tout cas c'est une réalité que par
exemple une personne comme lori je suis
pas sûr qu'elle sera rejetée pas si ça
va dit bien pris ou pas mais je sais pas
si elle serait là encore aujourd'hui si
elle n'était pas avec quelqu'un qui est
à un crampon d'universal donc donc c'est
quand même c'est quand même une réalité
que voilà il ya des petits arrangements
entre amis et des petits arrangements
avec les maisons du vélo et ça lui fait
elle a toujours été là elle fait pas où
il ya comme d'accord mais
ce qu'elle a fait pour les enfants et je
pense que s'il ajoutait franchement ce
serait malvenu la part des [ __ ] mais
rien de questions est la fille elle a
toujours été là a toujours répondu
présente je sais qu'elle s'implique
beaucoup
donc c'est vrai que forcément bon ses
effets oui bernard montiel non si ce qui
est vrai c'est que ils ont été
extrêmement déstabilisé par le départ de
jean jacques goldman qui était le boss
il tenait tout le monde ça moi je suis
allé tous les ans vos enfants à vos
concerts il tenait tout le monde c'est à
dire qu'on l'écouté et tout était décidé
avec son frère robert goldman c'est à
dire c'est plutôt robert qui va tout
reprendre là il ya déjà commencé à
reprendre c'est robert qu'on écoute
c'est vrai que les sketches se font avec
michaël youn se faisait avec palmade
bénabar michèle laroque
tu sais les entravant les chansons et
caetera et que là la bonne ambiance
forcément dans un groupe toujours des
petits soucis mais il ya tout de même
une bonne ambiance mais s'ils se
retrouvent tous les soirs à l'hôtel où
ils sont tous là j'ai pas le choix
alors je vous dirais dernières années
dans la presse et un grand nombre
d'artistes pour monde en parle ce soir
et myriam est elle relaye aussi ce que
disent certains artistes parce que voilà
il ya par exemple il ya jacques dutronc
qui a notamment examiné certains
artistes qui pour lui il était là que
pour se montrer booba n'a jamais voulu
rejoindre la troupe qu'il qualifie de
chorales quasi sectaire qui se fait de
la promo sur le malheur des autres
ces voix là il ya aussi plein de stars
qui veulent plus venir hélène ségara a
refusé d'y aller parce qu'elle a elle
dit que c'était la bonne poire qui
accepte et où muriel robin a aussi
décidé d'arrêter suite à des c'est pas
des fautes des gens forcément et gris ou
en fin de carrière c'est ça non muriel
robin non bon bah voilà donc et jacques
dutronc non plus et c'est une immense
star donc voilà donc c'est vrai et il ya
plein de gens aussi
moi je vous dis voilà ce qui se dit
voilà il ya stéphane guillon ci qui a
critiqué la troupe expliqué expliquant
qu'il s'agissait d'une bande fermé voilà
il dit voilà c'est à siliana qu'ils sont
entre eux et que il ya plein de gens qui
mériteraient d'y aller au 20 mai c'est
le cas elles rêvent d'y aller michèle
bernier elle a fait plein d'appels en
disant prenez moi promets moi prenez moi
pourrait elle ne sais pas pourquoi j'ai
merdé qui chante des emplumés et elle ne
sait pas pourquoi ils ne veulent pas les
noms auraient jamais non je sais moi je
suis d'accord sur ce point c'est que à
la base quand ça a été créé les restos
du coeur la première chanson il y avait
un sportif animateur télé c'était michel
drucker y avait des gens ont peur des
acteurs etc mais que je suis d'accord le
côté un peu entre eux soit entre
chanteurs il n'y a pas de l'émetteur de
risque est pas normal chéri là où vous
pourriez très bien y est on a demandé
le 20 mai sur tf1 non c'est vrai que la
presse
non mais c'est une règle d'or
l'animateur télé une règle d'or qui est
depuis le début qu'il dit n'est pas vrai
ça y avait michel drucker
oui mais tu rigoles ou quoi drucker a
chanté dont nationale sur scène je suis
n'importe quoi là et non non mais c'est
pas vrai n'était pas alors illégaux dans
la chanson tu disais c'est lui qui par
bernard et non non non et non écoute moi
écoute moi je tape à deux choses n'en
voyait pas pour autant juste mais c'est
parce que sa mère
mais ce que je suis un peu énervé la
même source que le montant était dans la
même chanson
tout était donc j'ai tout comme tout
comment ça s'est passé il y avait les
collèges était très proche de mon temps
donc j'ai toute l'histoire bon y'a mary
kerr lanouf ont fait ça n'ont pas
vraiment à la base ça devait être un
collectif ouvert à tous qui connaissent
pas la face depuis longtemps dans les
sachant pas comment la chanson à tous
les cas l'idée
oui absolument l'arrêt du chômage
absolument non bref au départ ce matin
connectique de gens connus qu'ils
pouvaient participer et aider la
connaissance de la cause et avait des
sportifs ou à les senteurs des
animateurs des acteurs donc je trouve
que effectivement le entre eux soit là
je suis désolé ça me gênerait pas qu'il
y ait d'autres gens et pas seulement des
chanteurs et parce que cette excuse moi
ça s'appelle du racisme c'est la
question à la productrice anne marcassus
même j'adore j'adore et anne marcassus
mais quel album bordel et les
formidables ce soir si vous regardez pas
assez vite je me affaires dit non sur
ces huit ce soit sinon je pense qu' une
nouvelle émission sur tf1 produit
d'ailleurs par anne marcassus et mathieu
je voulais du tout les salles d'or s'est
produite entre potes et du match c'est
un très bon point tout cas de la bouche
même d'un mac danemark a su qu est la
productrice hamadi on ne prend pas
d'animateur le cas au début du coeur
c'est nouveau qui a eu cet examen c'est
pas un chanteur cecab adams il n'est pas
chanteur est bien avait pourtant c'est
bien alors c'est assez fermé en import
mais parce qu'il n'est pas chanteur me
dis qu'il ya que des chanteurs et
qu'elle lui ni l'animateur
la liste des gens exclus ou qui ne sont
pas coopté s'allonge d'année en année il
faut pas être dupe non plus arrêté il ya
plein de nouveaux qui arrivent des trucs
j'ai été bon et y en a pleins patrick
sébastien n'a jamais voulu aller stromae
il avait dit je veux pas y aller parce
que c'est mon image qui va être
valorisés et pas la cause
il y en a eu plein tout le temps et ce
qui se passe c'est que le concert
représente 6 à 8% du budget d'accord
global et avec les ventes de cd dvd qui
chute et bien ils commencent à se poser
des questions ça ne va pas on peut dire
que ces manifs moi je dis la cause est
magnifique mais à l'intérieur de la
troupe il ya énormément de tensions sur
vous c'est une latina saison j'aimerais
voir son regard soi-disant ferai pas ce
que tu dis moi et je vous jure il ya
plein de gens il ya plein d'artistes qui
disent en ce moment pourquoi ne pas
créer voilà une autre troupe voilà plus
plus jeunes puis voilà je sais que
c'était dans les tuyaux
oui certains c'est ce que maître gims
voulais faire mais je crois vous l'aviez
vous aviez là mais l'info aussi
également c'est vrai faire un spectacle
ils veulent faire un autre menace alors
se font pas dire que les [ __ ]
existerait pas peut-être qu'il faudrait
faire deux spectacles pour les restos du
coeur ça serait se serait jamais d'être
ou non mais ça c'est ça qu'il faudrait
faire il ne fait pas de spectacle pour
les restos du coeur parce que les restos
du coeur ils en ont beaucoup vraiment
besoin avec la crise qui vient d'avoir
je peux vous dire qu'il ya beaucoup
beaucoup de gens qui croyaient ne jamais
aller au resto du coeur qui sont bien
obligés d'aller aider les restos du
coeur absolu
donc moi je me dis peut-être qu'il ya un
truc à faire c'est que tous ceux qui
veulent pas aller peut-être aux [ __ ]
ce que les [ __ ] c'est pas les restos
du coeur peut-être même boire avec les
gens qui s'occupent des [ __ ]
peut-être devoir faire une deuxième
exactement et un autre concert avec
peut-être des plus jeunes des plus et
plus voilà les déchets bon peut-être
voilà libres ne passe ne pas se déguiser
faire un vrai concert avec positionne
oui je pense sincèrement aussi qu'il
faudrait moderniser le spectacle dans le
sens où des [ __ ] moi j'ai trouvé
exceptionnel l'année dernière avec anne
marcassus et mathieu verboud tranche on
l'a même dit louis six meilleurs
spectacles à l'ific je trouve que d'un
point de vue du jeune j'ai toujours
trouvé que les [ __ ] c'est un peu
ringard c'est un peu toute l'assistance
et sa musique c'est ce qui s'est
sincèrement j'ai toujours pensé ça et je
me dis que d'inviter j'ai pas par
exemple des youtuber les youtube heures
c'est vraiment là
nir un peu médiatique et je me dis que
ça serait une très très bonne idée
d'inviter de youtube heures j'ai mené
mon enquête j'ai demandé à la famille
chou c'est vrai j'aurais dû faire un
coup cette année les chanteurs super
jeune ça serait cool j'ai mené mon
enquête je demandais à certains youtuber
adn youtuber très connus et ils m'ont
tous dit qu'ils n'ont jamais été
contacté je trouve ça quand même qu'on
en fait ça a attiré tellement de jeunes
ça tirait tout un nouveau public pour la
cause en plus que ça je trouve ça
vraiment bien et je suis vraiment
pourquoi il ya beaucoup de personnes qui
n'aiment pas y aller parce qu'avec
toutes les polémiques et c'est forcément
ça fou dans la sauce donc techniquement
j'ai on prend elle elle dit un truc
satiné c'est vrai que c'est ce qui
revient à moi je pourrais chose quand je
parle avec des allées les plus jeunes
tous à une dizaine ans les [ __ ] et
des fous c'est un peu ringarde tout ça
mais il faut qu'ils pensent à autre
chose il faut qu'il pense à la côte faut
qu'ils pensent aussi l'essentiel les
[ __ ] c'est juste là pour aider les
restos du coeur c'est pas pour avoir des
amis mais je mets cette chance et merci
aux artistes d'ailleurs des spectacles
parce que bien sûr un artiste la vie à
137 millions de repas servis mais c'est
magnifique ça c'est ce que font un arrêt
de travail comme un chien et c'est
encore plus louable d'y aller alors que
l'ambiance bernachon désolé tu dis qu
ils sont content tu retrouvé l'hôtel de
soi wen a toujours quel certains parmi
les 200 artistes ils sont tous retrouvés
sauf que l'artiste cdi sont arrivés au
bout d'un système ils sont tellement
nombreux
c'est comme se baigner au milieu n'a pas
des crabes ils ont tous des esgaulx
tellement qu'ils se chamaillent sur tout
at elle à la loge plus près de du
producteur que moi je suis je sais pas
limitée au restaurant alors bruce avec
les mesures sanitaires